bucky Brooks back here on the show how
are you bookie I'm doing great so let's
get to it right here who has impressed
the most who's shown up and you're like
okay that's that's what I expected from
the tape well obviously this everything
is around the quarterback's years people
were abuzz about the quarterbacks that
are in attendance it starts with Baker
Mayfield Josh Allen
two guys in any regard within the top
floor the quarterbacks in the class and
I think both of those guys have shown
impressive flashes when it comes to
Baker Mayfield
everyone understands that he is a guy
who's the ultimate gamer the more bodies
you put on the field the better he plays
and so going from individual to 707 to
team drills the more they put on him the
better he performs throws a great timing
and anticipation has a knack about him
and I think the most impressive part of
him is his alpha personality you can
tell that he's a natural leader guys
gravitate towards him and when you're
trying to figure out which quarterback
has the right mix you can tell that
Baker Mayfield has the it stuff inside
that makes people want to play for him
and Josh Allen you're talking about a
guy that is probably the perfect
quarterback on paper
meaning size talent tools he has all the
things that you look for on a
prototypical quarterback he can spin it
he's athletic he can make plays in the
pocket and outside the pocket the
biggest thing that's preventing people
from jumping all in on Josh Allen is his
consistency and consistent as a thrower
has been inconsistent with his ball
placement regardless of that there's
still some coaches that belief with that
kind of talent you take a chance on them
because you can develop the other stuff
oh yeah he could be a fun line player in
their club and also Bucky you know we
played a couple of his sound bites from
the Senior Bowl this week one where he
expertly handled the idea of being
drafted by Cleveland saying that he
wants to be that guy that whoever is
that guy is gonna be lionized as the guy
forever and he wants to be in that
position and then when asked about what
he would you say to Cleveland if they
pass up on you he expertly handled that
also for a kid that's playing in Wyoming
he seems to be media ready to to me
Bucky yes sir
he certainly has understanding of what
is going to be asked of him and he wants
to be the quote-unquote guy when he gets
to the next level the way he and of the
Cleveland situation the way he's handled
some of the tough questions that we've
locked at him because they're they're
questions about his ability to compete
against the league competition based on
how you performed against Paulo five
schools at whelming one touchdown eight
interceptions whenever he played in a
big game
he didn't necessarily perform like the
best guy on the field and so as an
evaluator you're trying to figure out do
I wait my evaluation on his potential
for his production he is trying to
answer those questions down here soon
you boy this week okay Bucky Brooks
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
from Mobile Alabama and then when it
comes down to it for first blush here we
are on the outset of Super Bowl week do
you think the first overall quarterback
is in Mobile today no I don't think the
first overall quarterback is in Mobile
and the way that I will preface this is
if the Cleveland Browns are picking
number one I don't believe they're gonna
pick Josh Yellin and I don't believe
that they will think they could make it
I believe the Cleveland Browns are going
to sign a veteran quarterback via free
agency or via trade and then they're
using number one pick on a guy like Sam
Donnell and the reason I say am dog is
just because I think there's a
fascination with his intangibles his it
factor his ability to make plays on
script and unscripted I think separates
them from others now it's either most
ready to play no I say that will
probably go to Josh Rosen or even a
Baker Mayfield but in terms of having
the stuff that people want and a
franchise quarterback I think Sam John
will get to not I look for Cleveland to
double down on the quarterback position
that is why I say I'm John I'm gonna be
the number one overall pick but he may
not take play next year because maybe a
guy like Alex meant for someone else in
the position one year why would Alex
Smith decide to go to Cleveland and just
be a placeholder then or or if he
struggles in week six week seven and he
knows that Hugh Jackson's on the griddle
that he'll just push the darn about at
any veteran quarterback go to a
situation like that do you think Bucky
well I think a couple of different
reasons why Alex Smith mean I have a
choice because he may be
trade offering as opposed to her free
agent so he may not have a choice in
terms of where he goes but he does have
a trust factor with John Dorsey based on
what they were able to do coming from
San Francisco to Kansas City if they
don't go with Alec Smith and that means
they had will have to pay more money for
veteran quarterback maybe they do delve
into the Kirk Cousins we chase maybe
they do look at one of these other
Creators that could be available but
based on what I'm hearing in the way
that I think the board is going to shape
up the Cleveland Browns need a veteran
quarterback they need a veteran
quarterback because their room is full
of 25 years or less guy they need they
need someone beyond the 20-something to
help them come to right the ship look at
them to sign a veteran and then double
down and bring this young quarterback so
they can be a placeholder remember
Carson Palmer played under Hugh Jackson
in Cincinnati and Cincinnati Carson
Palmer was the number one pick who sat
behind Jon Kitna for four years so there
is a bit of precedent and taking that
approach with a number one pick and a
veteran quarterback and letting their
veteran quarterback land a position for
a year before letting the other guy take
off so who is everyone who's buzzing
about who is everybody buzzing about
that wasn't on the radar screen
going into mobile so far Bucky will
continue to talk about office and pass
catchers people are buzzing about James
Washington to receive him from Oklahoma
State we knew that he was fast we did he
was dynamic has been pretty clean in
terms of running routes and being able
to stretch the defense people are
excited about him but the guy that has
kind of come off the grid has been -
Sean helmet in the wide receiver from
Penn State he might be the best route
runner down here his patience his time
and his precision getting in and out of
his breaks
separation from some of the other guys
in the group he has certainly made an
impression and the last guy to everybody
wanted to see Marcus Davenport the pass
rusher from Texas San Antonio hasn't
necessarily dominated but when you see
it aside you see that Lance you see the
tools and the potential I expect him to
be a top two in talent a top 10 player
by the time we get to the end of this
process all right Bucky last one for you
down there in Mobile
what is the the scouts the coaches the
buzz about Super Bowl 50 - what people
think is going to happen next week when
the Patriots and Eagles lock it up
I think it's a pretty compelling magic I
think when you talk to the people here
they just come in Doug Peterson in the
staff of the job that they done with the
Eagles the way they're able to continue
to keep it rolling with Nick Foles in
place says a lot about their offensive
creativity their adaptability and their
ability to be patient with a quarterback
who is trying to find his way they did a
great job in the end they think that the
Eagles will have to quote-unquote beat
the Patriots because we've seen time and
time again the Patriots won't lose the
game they will wait for you to mess up
you saw it happen in the championship
game where the Jacksonville Jaguars
couldn't put them away there's a belief
that if the Eagles get up they got to
continue put the foot on the gas didn't
have to close them out because you let
the Patriots hang around with Tom Brady
if they're close they're within two
touchdowns in the fourth quarter
we have seen T beat we'll do it over and
over again that is the belief from all
the coaches who scouts down here so
don't take don't take a knee with two
timeouts left in 55 seconds on the first
half clock remaining Bucky and I think I
think the operative phrase is all gas no
brakes
you got to finish that you got to finish
the view you got to roll it down you
mm-hmm
is that what you believe to that your
belief about Super Bowl 50 to be oh I do
I mean I think I think to look at either
the world position to be able to do it
but I think the thing that everyone is
holding out or two games the Atlanta
Falcons last year in Super Bowl 51 when
they dominated the game pretty much for
three quarters and let it slip and then
the Jacksonville Jaguars you basically
did the same thing there's a self-doubt
that creeps in when you want to jump
into believing another team you want
that can they really finish the deal
with everything on the line we've seen
the Patriots do it time and time again I
mean you just wonder can they close it
out I think they're talented enough to
do it is just a matter can they finish
the deal when they have the opportunity
to all right buck these safe travels
we'll see you soon back at the shop you
got at Bucky Brooks the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience